[Musique]
c'était un moment vraiment
extraordinaire parce que c'est un grand
privilège de défiler sur la plus belle
écran d'avenue du monde qui est les
Champs-Élysées et donc c'était vraiment
incroyable j'ai profité de moment
je les ai trouvés remarquables déjà à
témoigner les applaudissements comme
disait le colonel ça voilà nous avons
été
fortement
nous sommes satisfaits
et je pense que les images du défilé
prendront la place qu'il faut dans nos
dans nos souvenirs
une très grande joie parce que c'est la
première fois que je sors de mon pays
déjà et c'est pour représenter mon école
et mon pays aux Champs-Élysées
[Musique]
ça sera également très utile pour nos
deux pays parce qu'il est bon que très
tôt
les personnels qui auront à travailler
ensemble au cours de mission
certainement international se
connaissent déjà dès le bas âge
bon ça se passe ça s'est passé de
manière amicale quoi comme des
retrouvailles
[Musique]
moi je trouve très important de jeunes
français
dès la classe de seconde dès la classe
de de classe préparatoires puissent
échanger sur ce qu'il se passe en
Afrique de la même façon et très
important à mon sens que de jeunes
élèves africains puissent venir dans nos
lycées eux aussi venir comprendre notre
monde la France le monde européen le
monde occidental et que tout ça
aboutisse finalement à une meilleure
connaissance mutuelle
[Musique]
c'est vrai que de bons profits de
d'essayer de calquer le modèle français
qui déjà une très grande renommée à
l'international et afin de pouvoir à
faire avancer
celui du de mon pays d'origine qui est
le Gabon
[Musique]